some people may even say you know you
uh are part of the swamp as a lobbyist
you know i think lobbyists would you say
lobbyists have done a lot of damage i
think lobbyists well it depends on what
they do i mean lobbying is government
affairs what does i mean you walked into
an office of a congressman you think
they're the experts on all the topics
they're dealing with in the committees
no a good government affairs firm is
providing information for people to make
decisions now there's corruption within
the system what good does a lobbyist do
like if i were to say a you know what
what good does a cop do okay i can say
what good a cop does what good does a
military soldier do what good does a
whoever what good what good does allah
provide information factual information
on whatever the issues are that they're
representing uh in the case of foreign
government representing foreign
governments they facilitate
understanding because people they don't
they they don't
people don't talk the same to each other
they don't understand the same to each
other and
in a good lobbyist which has become a
pejorative term
but a good lobbyist is somebody who
brings information
finds out what the problems are goes
back and gets responses to the problems
and comes back and
that's the mundane work that gets done
in the legislative process and the
regulatory process all the time
what you read about are the excesses
hunter biden going into the state
department and saying that
we need to keep we have we need to back
off on prosecutors uh in ukraine uh come
coming down on barisma that's that's
what lobbying is viewed but that's not
lobbying aren't there that's political
political influence wouldn't you say
lobbies are like the ultimate spinners
though like they're the ultimate
spinners they'll spin any story into
they'll use some factual things and then
they'll spin it into whatever story or
narrative they want to tell but it is a
form but they're like the ultimate
ultimate spinners well
they that's one of the things they do
yes absolutely but again
don't
deceive yourself
the system in washington is not meant
for congressmen to know everything and
their staffs know everything about all
the issues that they on the committees
they sit on they need information from
outside to make informed decisions and
good lobbyists provide that information
it's there's some of it is spending
the congressmen have to in the end make
judgments
isn't it all money driven meaning like
a lobbyist is going to
tell them that information based on how
much they're getting paid by that
company that repre that they represent
but the member of congress understands
that the lobbyist is showing up on
behalf of a t
and so that comes with a certain frame
of understanding um and the information
they're getting from at t they get and
they have to contextualize that versus
what they're getting from a company
that's opposing att you know buying time
warner or whatever the case might be
what would happen if lobbyists were just
completely eliminated then you would
have a lot of legislation that was
uninformed
but watch this though check this out so
about half of retiring
senators and a third of retiring house
members retire as lobbyists
we've got this image in our head of
lobbies you know who's the lobbyist who
the teachers union
okay teachers are the lobbyists i agree
so you're going to take them out
no no one's talking to teachers you you
know they're talking about taking a
lobbying company out but the teachers
union is a lobbyist
aarp is a lobbyist they're also there's
an element of them that's also corrupt
but my point is there's a role they
serve and when you start saying take
lobbyists out of the equation you're
taking everybody out of the way who
would win elections if there was no
lobbyists like let's just say it's it's
it's criminal
to hire lobbyists or lobbyist firm
who who would that favor the most if all
of that was gone and out
i don't even know how you could do that
to start with but if you i think but if
you're saying take
take
lobbyist out you really i think what
you're saying is take the money out of
contributions sure if there's no money
there's no lobbying but again that means
the teachers union doesn't get to
contribute the afl cio doesn't get to
contribute i mean start and you think
they're going to give that up
no way i'm not saying they're going to
give it up by the way i i actually don't
think it's going to happen not in my
lifetime i'm 43 it ain't going to happen
in my lifetime but all i'm asking is
you know if we did in everywhere who
does it hurt who does it benefit
look i i think
done correctly it hurts
good legislation
i mean if you i mean if you take out the
information flow that lobbying companies
that you
bring to the system
how does a member of congress
get their information where are they
going to get it
they're not they're not going to
intuitively know the technicalities of
of
big tech and the the exemptions that
they have uh as
from from publishing they're not going
to totally know that a friend of mine
was a was a lobbyist and a very high
paid lobbyist he made very good money
okay very very good money
and he left and got into a completely
different industry i said so why did you
get into lobbying this if you know you
can make a lot of money i made a lot of
money i said okay this whole thing about
you know politics is dirty and all this
stuff he says listen
some of the stuff i did as a lobbyist it
eventually got to a point where i'm like
holy [ __ ] if i continue like this this
thing's eventually going to catch up to
me with what we're doing with our team
how
how ugly is the world of lobbying
meaning the power plays
is is it
you know how okay we ask this question
regularly we you know hey if you want to
build a championship in football what
matters the most the gm the owner the
quarterback the running back the defense
all the stuff you go through offensive
coordinator recruit who do you put up
there right
if we want somebody to win okay if we
want somebody to do into a candidate to
win
how important of a role does a lobbyist
play to help that person win how
important of a role does a lobbyist play
to get an amazon who moves a part of
their headquarters closer to you know
virginia or dc to pass some laws how
important of a role do lobbyists place
to pass some of these laws for them
well those are two different things
getting elected versus government both
of them yeah getting elected
you know money is important
but the money comes from a lot of
sources not just lobbyists so i i would
not make lobbying as the distinction
i mean
they're probably people and the
republicans probably feel like they're
outmanned in getting uh by the democrats
and getting lobbyist money if you look
at lobbyist money most of it goes to
democrats a lot of it does
but i don't think that matters to
getting elected i think what matters
getting elected is the your issue agenda
and then as an incumbent what you've
done
at the end of the day
the american people usually figure
things out i'm a big believer in our
system
they usually figure things out they can
be fooled for an election cycle
but they they generally figure things
out and so
lobbying to me is more impactful in
governance not in elections money's
going to come from somewhere regardless
you take lobbying money out it's still
going to come from somewhere
and and so getting elected is a
different
paradigm from my standpoint
as far as governing is concerned
lobbying plays a constructive role
if you you frame things correctly it's
still going to be up to the member to
make a decision
on the information that he gets
um and
it's not like it's happening in a vacuum
a lobbying you get lobbyists on both
sides of issues more often times than
multiple sides of issues
and so yes that puts
a uh a responsibility on the member to
understand the facts but that's part of
his job is to understand the facts you
got to make sure he gets the facts and
if he's getting both sides of the facts
he's got enough to make judgments
i would you know
make the point that special interests
are not particularly necessarily
lobbyists that control members of
congress but industries
and
how do you get i mean and that's part of
if you come from a coal mining area coal
mining industry is going to have an
impact on the members of congress from
that area is that wrong
probably not because that's the area
they're from and they need to understand
those issues
it's where
where i have my problem with washington
and where i think trump tapped into
something in 2016
was where members of congress will be
for something when they're in power
and then when they lose power they're
against what they were for
on an issue
and and that hypocrisy
gets is what gets lo gets give an
example
obama or trump um well i mean neither in
that sense i'm talking more
congressional i mean i'll give you an
example it's a political it's a a
political one but it's nonetheless the
filibuster in the senate
how many you've seen all the eclipse the
schumer and the democrats being against
the filibuster being removed when they
had the when they were in the minority
in the senate and now they're for the
filibuster being
[Music]
getting rid of it why because it
enhances their power so it's the
equation is defined by what it does for
power not what it does for democracy um
mcconnell's done the same thing same
thing on both sides and mc and uh
trump campaigned against both of them
he they were the same can't stand trump
yeah well they're absolutely it's
probably mutual it's probably it is
but the point is why doesn't trump like
mcconnell
because mcconnell to trump is the same
thing as schumer is the trump as far as
he's just a swamp creature he's a swamp
creature why doesn't mcconnell like
trump because mcconnell is a swamp
creature and trump wants to get rid of
this disrupter yeah and so
will they ever see i i mean trump no i
was there's no hope for reconciliation
well no there's always hope for
reconciliation because there'll be
mutuality of interest
will they ever like each other no
but will they ever work together yeah i
think they would so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]